el próximo órgano del que hablaremos en
nuestro recorrido por el abdomen es el
páncreas aquí he dibujado el páncreas y
dejen de escribir páncreas
este es el páncreas es posible que hayas
oído hablar de él antes el páncreas está
debajo y detrás del estómago y abraza la
primera parte del intestino delgado que
creo que puedes reconocer es el duodeno
de hecho lo envuelve un poco más de lo
que he dibujado aquí pero se ubica por
aquí algunos dicen que el páncreas está
en un compartimento completamente
separado del estómago del intestino
delgado del intestino grueso incluso del
hígado no está en el peritoneo que es
donde se encuentra el resto del
intestino el peritoneo es una palabra
elegante para decir abdomen
de modo que el estómago está en el
peritoneo también el hígado el intestino
delgado el intestino grueso todos están
en el peritoneo pero el páncreas es
diferente porque se encuentra en el
retroperitoneo cuando decimos
retroperitoneo significa que está en la
parte posterior del auto
ahora no está solo muchos de los órganos
que se encuentran a través del abdomen
también están ahí la aorta abdominal la
vena cava inferior que puede ser que
hayas escuchado de ellas en otro lugar
también se encuentran en este
compartimento diferente de hecho para
los profesionales médicos es muy
importante tener en cuenta al páncreas
por un par de razones en primer lugar
libera un montón de enzimas poderosas de
las cuales vamos a hablar en un minuto
estas enzimas poderosas pueden digerir
muchas macromoléculas de lo que comemos
pero también de cosas que recubren
nuestras membranas celulares o componen
otras partes de nuestro cuerpo no sólo
en el retroperitoneo sino también en el
peritoneo el tórax en cualquier otro
lugar de nuestro cuerpo
entonces libera enzimas poderosas en
segundo lugar el páncreas es un poco
extraño ya que no está encapsulado no
está encapsulado a diferencia de otros
órganos como el hígado el hígado tiene
la cápsula hepática el riñón está
cubierto por su propia cápsula
pero el páncreas es esencialmente una
mezcla de células que están colgando de
alguna manera en el retroperitoneo eso
hace que sea un poco difícil
especialmente para los cirujanos que
tienen que operar cerca no quieres
meterte con el páncreas porque tiene
enzimas poderosas que podrían causar
mucho daño a su alrededor si fueran
liberadas de modo que no es de extrañar
que el páncreas tenga un apodo especial
muchos médicos consideran que el
páncreas es el león del abdomen por lo
importante que es y por lo poderosas que
son las enzimas que provienen de él así
como el león en la jungla no quieres
meterte con el páncreas
tomemos unos minutos y hablemos sobre lo
que hace que el páncreas sea tan
especial fisiológicamente el páncreas
libera dos tipos de cosas o tiene dos
componentes principales uno tenemos el
páncreas exocrino la idea detrás del
páncreas exocrino es que tomas sales y
enzimas estas poderosas enzimas de las
que hablé antes tomas sales y enzimas y
las libera en el duodeno
lo que recuerdas dónde está el duodeno
es la primera parte del intestino justo
después del estómago
de modo que el páncreas exocrino cumple
con cuatro roles principales en primer
lugar como recordarás el páncreas libera
su contenido en el duodeno piensa en lo
que el duodeno está recibiendo de
antemano como hablamos en el vídeo sobre
el estómago está recibiendo un montón de
equipo que ha sido digerido por ácido
gástrico o ácido clorhídrico así que
necesitará algo para neutralizar todo
ese ácido y el páncreas exocrino libera
bicarbonato el bicarbonato servirá para
neutralizar el ácido gástrico se
neutralizará el bajo ph que está
recibiendo del estómago en forma de
ácido gástrico recuerda nuevamente el
ácido gástrico es ácido clorhídrico a
continuación a medida que avancemos
hablaré sobre algunas de estas enzimas
poderosas de las que discutimos
anteriormente una de ellas que mencioné
brevemente cuando estábamos hablando de
la boca es la amilasa si recuerdas la
amilasa es responsable de la
del almidón y el almidón es solo un
montón de carbohidratos apilados unos
sobre otros
de modo que descomponemos el almidón en
carbohidratos más pequeños solo
escribiré carbohidratos más pequeños por
ahora eso incluye cosas como monómeros
de glucosa o incluso disacárido otra
enzima que también liberamos del
páncreas exocrino al duodeno es algo
llamado lipasa la lipasa nos recuerda de
nuevo a la boca porque su nombre sugiere
que descompone los lípidos
específicamente tomara triglicéridos que
puedo dibujar aquí este es un
triglicéridos
tiene estas tres cadenas de ácidos
grasos que salen de la cabeza del
glicerol tomara triglicéridos que
descompondrá en ácidos grasos libres y
se verán así esta es la parte ácida y
esta es la parte del ácido graso también
tomara mono glitz heridos.los mono gris
heridos se ven así los llamamos mono
porque sólo tienen una cadena de ácidos
grasos también podríamos tener
diglicerido que creo que podrías
adivinar cómo
los cíclidos van a tener dos cadenas de
ácidos grasos ahí los tienes también
liberada glicerol el glicerol es lo que
se obtiene cuando logra deshacerse de
todas sus cadenas de ácidos grasos y
aquí están todos uso h esto es lo que
hará la lipasa y es similar a la lipasa
lingual que tienes en la boca pero en la
boca principalmente es por el gusto
cuando se digiere el triglicéridos y en
el duodeno esta enzima funciona para
descomponer los triglicéridos de una
manera mayor y finalmente la última
función del páncreas exocrino involucra
a sus enzimas proteolíticas sólo
escribiré proteolíticas hay dos tipos de
enzimas proteolíticas que libera trips y
no gen o y también kim o ésta es una
palabra más larga como trips y no gen o
aquí debes notar algo cada vez que ves
el sufijo og no como vemos aquí se
refiere a algo que se llama ximo gen o
un theme og no es una enzima que está
inactiva en este momento porque tiene un
enlace adicional por lo general 1
hace peptídicos que debe romperse para
que comience a funcionar de modo que el
trip sino que no es la forma inactiva de
la tripsina así como el quimo tryp sino
que no es la forma inactiva de la quimio
tripsina así que necesitan ser activadas
y esto sucede en el duodeno hay una
enzima que se encuentra allí llamada
entero peptidasa hay un montón de entero
peptidasas en el duodeno la
interoperatividad se romperá el trips y
no gen o para formar tripsina la
tripsina es la forma activa que podrá
descomponer las proteínas lo que estamos
haciendo en realidad es causar una
reacción en cadena porque una vez que se
forma la tripsina el siguiente paso en
la activación del quimo trips y no g no
se logra mediante la tripsina la
tripsina dividir a equipo trips y no
ajeno para formar esta es una palabra
muy larga quimo tripsina y estás
descompondrán las proteínas en el
duodeno ahora te pregunto si estas
enzimas que están inactivas debido a que
generalmente tienen un enlace simple qué
pasa cuando ese enlace que las hace
inactivas
digamos que tienes un accidente
automovilístico y tienes un golpe en el
estómago con suficiente fuerza que puede
proporcionar energía de activación para
romper un enlace y convertir el trips y
no gen o en tripsina qué pasaría bueno
como mencionamos anteriormente debido a
que el páncreas no está encapsulado la
tripsina activada pasar a activar el
quimo trips y no gen o en quimo tripsina
y luego romper a proteínas donde sea que
estén podrían ser proteínas de la
membrana podrían ser proteínas que están
en la superficie del duodeno podrían ser
las proteínas que digerimos en nuestra
comida o podrían ser proteínas presentes
en el páncreas puedes ver por qué el
páncreas es tan temido es por eso que no
quieres dañarte el páncreas porque
podemos activar estas enzimas mortales
que deberían estar funcionando en el
duodeno